bonsoir michel piccoli vous regardez en
train de regarder les images de ce film
vous les admirer vous étiez content de
ce que de ce film content de ce que j'ai
fait mais au nom mais extrêmement
heureux de l'avoir fait et ne vient pas
fait avec tout ce qu'ils ont fait les
acteurs tout le monde bien c'est ça qui
me bouleversait depuis tellement
longtemps de voir ce qui se passait
derrière la caméra c'est à dire la
fabrication profonde se prêtent
bouleversante de la fabrication d'un
film ça vous manquait de passer de
l'autre côté de la caméra après cette
carrière que vous avez eu parce que vous
vous connaissez les réalisateurs vous
connaissez le métier oui mais vous je le
connais je le connais très très
profondément très passionnément
c'est bien parce que je les aime
passionnément que j'ai voulu rentrer
dedans et non pas rester à l'image va
être pour dire quelque chose de précis
avec ce film oui enfin de précis ou est
ce que j'ai voulu dire
je pense que je vais vous le dire j'ai
voulu dire que les gens dits ordinaires
les gens dits normaux pouvait avoir des
fulgurances de passion aidant vie
d'autres choses voilà et la voilà ce que
j'ai voulu essayer de raconter à travers
une tranche de vie c'est-à-dire d'une
espace de tribus moi je dis des tranches
de vie ou étrange de même c'est pas une
histoire de famille seules trois
familles et des enfants et un patin
patriat ja grand père tout à fait
extravagant libertaire est amoureux fou
des femmes depuis sa première femme
jusqu'à sa petite fille superbe avec
laquelle il va pas repartir pour faire
un voyage lequel on ne sait pas bien le
personnage qu'il a fait un autre voyage
va très probablement se suicider à coup
sûr définitivement un autre va partir
sur son camion
parce que pour beaucoup de deux routiers
de voyageurs de la route le camion de
glaces massive à quoi y avoir des crêtes
dans pas longtemps ils vous déclarer
qu'il soit exploité et qu'en même temps
c'est un métier libère
c'est un métier extravagant le métier de
routier michel piccoli canton quand on
regarde ce film on pense aussi à tous
ceux que vous admirez dans le métier que
vous avez rencontré ce qu'ils vous ont
influencé profondément secrètement
sûrement mais je n'ai j'ai fait ça en
toute liberté
je les pensais à oka en tout cas depuis
l'écriture première jusqu'à l'écriture
dernière c'est à dire le montage très
rapidement un mot sur les acteurs ils
sont tous comme on dit des gueules brûle
sur des gueules mais surtout ils ont un
plaisir d'être acteur et j'ai eu la
chance que tous ces acteurs que j'ai
choisi si je puis dire
il ya deux ans monte mon estime me sont
restés fidèles voilà merci à michel
piccoli nous avoir rendu visite je
rappelle donc alors voilà sort mercredi
dans les salles avec maurice car elle
michel geiser dominique blanc arnaud
rolland amstutz bien d'autres encore
c'est à voir
pascal enzo merci